hello everybody
uh first of all let me just say how
honored jennifer and i are to be here
with all the amazing speakers we've had
and be in a room full of experts and
people who are interested in this topic
what we want to talk about today is
google and some of the initiatives that
we have launched just within the last
year to address
health and wellness issues with our
employees so let me start just by laying
the context of
google who we are and why we care about
some of these issues so at the core of
google is this concept of innovation
it's very important to who we are as a
company and that's pretty obvious
because in the late 1990s it was an
innovation that launched google with our
search engine
we've had a couple of other product
innovations that came out just within
the last year so and i think they're
kind of fun
just to uh see what they are but before
we get there actually let me just say
that
this
this concept of innovation
was codified in our founders letter in
2004 this is the ipo letter that was
written by our founders and i love this
line google is not a conventional
company we do not intend to become one
and the way that's experienced every day
by google employees is that we're
encouraged to ask very audacious
questions big what if questions about
our products about all the work that we
do whether you're in finance or whether
you're in engineering so the biggest
most audacious question of all in my
opinion is the one that's linked to our
mission which is what if we could
organize all the world's information and
make it universally accessible and
usable well we're making some good
progress on that one
a couple of other fun ones that i just
wanted to
run by you
includes what if you could explore a
coral reef from your desktop any of you
who have used google maps probably have
noticed there's a street view option and
you can look around you you can now have
basically street view under the water
kind of cool
another one what if all the great art of
the world were available to you anywhere
at any time
we're going around the world to the best
museums and where we're invited to do so
photograph the paintings put them online
so that you can visit any museum whether
or not you're actually in the city and
this is my personal favorite which is
what if you could wear the internet in
these fabulous glasses that look really
cool so there's a little thing there and
it actually access access accesses the
internet and it's called project glass
so these are the sorts of innovations
that we have going on on our product
side and now i'm about to say something
that's going to cause most of you to
lose interest in the rest of the talk
and that is that jennifer and i are not
product managers
we are not the engineers creating these
amazing things we are coming to you from
hr human resources
known to be the
the foundation of in innovation at any
company
okay so keep listening uh
just because we're in hr does not mean
that we do not have the same
motivation to be innovative and ask big
questions that occurs at the rest of the
company the diff one of the differences
though we're not trying to impact the
experience of billions of people the
billions of people who are doing web
searches every day but instead we're
trying to impact the experience of about
35 000 people who are working in 70
locations across 40 countries around the
world who are google employees or what
we call googlers and we ask ourselves
lots of big what-if questions in hr like
what if everybody had a world-class
manager
what if it took us one week to onboard
new employees instead of six months
what if we knew your career development
needs before you did and and offered you
exactly what you needed before you asked
those are the sorts of questions we ask
now we have a group called the people in
innovation lab
the pi lab is what we call it internally
which is a group of social scientists
who try to tackle these questions
through data analytics and world-class
research so i'm going to talk to you
today and jennifer will get into the
specifics of one big what if question we
have on health side
what if working at google added two
years to your life what are the kinds of
things that we would have to do
to you and with you during your time at
google to make this a possibility
knowing that you won't be with google
for the rest of your life maybe you will
but a lot of people won't
so this is the big what if question for
us and at this point in the presentation
we could talk about a number of things
we could talk about the medical
decisions that people are making for
themselves and for their families on a
daily weekly monthly quarterly basis we
could talk about investments in your
retirement account so you have what you
need to grow old gracefully but instead
we're going to talk about food
now food is everywhere at google it's as
core to our culture as innovation is and
there are four reasons that i wanted to
talk about food as the example today the
first is this panel is right before
lunch so we wanted you to salivate as
you looked at these beautiful pictures
of food
the second is because of the abundance
of food at google we serve breakfast
lunch and dinner free of charge to any
employee who wants it and our mountain
view campus alone which is our
headquarters we have 24 different cafes
that are available to people so lots of
food available and the pictures don't
lie it tastes really good and our chefs
take special care in what they prepare
the third reason to talk about food is
because the decisions you make about the
calories you consume and the food that
you eat
every single day has long-term impact on
your health that's what the research is
leading us towards so when you're
spending so much of your time at work
you're at work five days a week you're
taking your meals there that's a
significant opportunity for us to
influence your choice
there's also
something that's not as fact-based it's
more of an
internal anecdote but there's something
called the google 15 and that's what we
want nooglers which are new employees
that they should expect to gain in
weight and during the first six months
at google and i know what you're
thinking but i can tell you before i
gain my google 15 that was this big
really little now
and here's one here's an example of of
choice
and why that's really important when we
talk about food
last week i looked at the menu for one
cafe in the new york city office for one
meal and it was lunch and i came up with
uh there were four different pages to
the menu this is what people confront on
a daily basis so
you could choose to sample all seven
dessert items you could go to
the
the grill you could try some ceviche and
it's at this point of choice that we
have an opportunity to influence the
behaviors of our google
employees thanks brian so so choice
provides the opportunity to nudge
and nudges has received a great deal of
attention recently due in in large part
to some exceptional work by a number of
behavioral economists and social
psychologists
but an edge is more than a reminder or
making a decision for people rather it
it builds on the understanding of how
the mind works
and
more to the point how it doesn't always
work like we think it does and certainly
doesn't always work the way we would
like it to
uh
but part of
part of the point i want to make here is
that that we don't
do our research from a blank slate
i working in the people innovation lab
has been an amazing experience i i had
started the silicon valley back in the
late 90s and about 2002 when my career
options were barista at starbucks
i fled to academia
for the money
and
yeah i came back to industry but i came
back for the data uh and i was talking
with thomas getz last night over dinner
and he he
in hearing about the work of our lab
talked about matt's rats in a maze
for obvious reasons this is not the
phrase i like to use when we talk about
the research we do but perhaps for less
obvious reasons because we see our
employees as partners in research
and
uh
part of that is
we're trying to do this collaboratively
so so i do i do a lot of work in
building research partnerships across
academia and industry and i do a
workshop at a conference and i got a
question from a student once who said
how do i get access to subjects at
companies
to play but first off they're called
employees
um not not subjects
uh
and i say this because we we do our
research with our employees not not to
them
and part of that means starting with a
fairly sophisticated understanding of
human behavior as sophisticated as
we can get from the state of social
science art so we are inspired by and
hope to contribute to the work that has
been done but by many other folks
so
thinking about
choice
and the nudges that are available to us
we we think about as on the previous
slide the cognitive motivational and
affective choices that people make
so let's talk some more about food
decisions are costly they require effort
this is effort we'd like to see more
often spent on
mapping the coral reefs of the world
but
people come to eat
so it's that we also hear from our
googlers that they want to be healthier
these are things they're actually asking
for to help make decisions so can we
help influence choice by providing the
right information at the right time so
we conducted a simple experiment
building on the research of brian
wonsick and others at cornell that
indicates that among other things
there's a very strong relationship
between the size of the container and
how much you eat
so
we
put out plates so imagine you walk into
one of the cafes that brian described
and you see
all this wonderful food and you go to
grab your plate and in addition to the
standard plate you're used to there's
also a small plate
we counted how many plates people chose
which do you choose i will tell you that
most did in fact choose the large plate
uh in 79 in fact i mean you thought you
saw the food it's amazing
so then
we described the research
we told people a bit about
this connection
we explained what was going on
and then we counted again
and we found that we saw a 50 increase
in the choice of small plates over large
plates
and a great deal of satisfaction with
having the option
uh
and most of our people agreeing that it
was very helpful
in controlling their portion size
so what's interesting for me here is is
that it's not always just enough to
provide the nudge but in providing
people with information and giving them
the power to make the decisions to make
them in an informed way has some
substantial
substantial impact
that said we also know that cafes are
not the only place where people eat
we have at google
something we call micro kitchens which
is a terrible misnomer there's nothing
micro about these kitchens
it's where people snack
they're great again a gathering place
for folks
oh yes
one of the great things about being in
an applied setting is that as i
mentioned
we're informing action and so when we
did an experiment the experiment was
done but our work was not and so now
small plates is simply a matter of it's
what we do it's a program this is one
example of how the small plates have
continued to roll out at google
all right so back to the micro kitchens
this is how we used to stock m m's
yeah it used to be like there are a
couple problems with this now here's the
case i talked previously about wanting
to make
choices easier here's an example where
we wanted to make a choice
harder
not take it away but make it something
that you did deliberately right so here
the m m now it's cereal but it used to
be m m's and everything else so
this something that wasn't so healthy
for you was given equal weight and
availability as something that was
perhaps a healthier choice and portion
control you anyone who's had the
experience of buying bulk food you
realized that you ended up with far more
chocolate covered raisins than you
probably intended so what are you going
to do you're not going to throw them out
um you're probably gonna end up eating
them so similarly so we redesigned the
micro kitchens
now you see the fruit is up front and
center it's beautiful there are other
options in the bins but we didn't take
the m m's away we just made them a
little more difficult to get to
so here they are on these opaque bins
they're labeled and what we found in the
seven weeks following this change
googlers in the new york office ate 3.1
million fewer calories from m ms
by making the portions easier to control
and requiring a more deliberate choice
in the part of employees
all right
so let's return to that audacious
question what if working at google added
two years to your life
so i want to leave you with three points
the first is that we make many small
decisions every day what to eat what to
snack on whether to snack whether to
save for retirement all of these things
can add up and at the right time in the
future could make all the difference to
you
my second point though is that
so
not not all companies are google and
have free cafes and free not so micro
kitchens but we spend
enormous amounts of our elections in
organizations and these are contexts
that guide and shape decisions
we are architects of choice in hr is how
we think of it in many ways what can any
organization do to support those healthy
kinds of choices be they stress related
mental health related physical health
related there are many opportunities and
not just at work but at home there's no
reason why we can't all downsize our
plate size or or hide our m ms
but then my final point is what happens
when we remember where the m ms are
right so much of the research and
nudging
is one-time
one-shot decisions
how do we help people form habits
how do we
make these behaviors consistent because
we eat every day
so
finally i've been asked well aren't
these nudges
manipulative
and as i think about that part of my
response is that we are being nudged
every day in directions that oftentimes
we don't want to go
why not try to nudge people in a
respectful way while maintaining options
in the direction that
for us that we hear from our employees
they do want to go
so
we've recently started these initiatives
they're new for us we plan to track them
for as long as we're around
we very much look forward to learning
from all of you and the amazing work
that's done and to reporting back our
findings over the years to come thank
you very much
you